[music]
Quick show of hands. How many of you
have used an Uber to get here today?
>> I guess quite a lot. Actually,
>> less than I expected. [laughter]
>> Yeah. So, we all know Uber and Uber Eats
as our everyday go-to apps for traveling
and getting food. But behind the scenes,
there is something much bigger
happening. Uber was built to move people
and things but is now running an AI
business using its global ondemand
network as a data engine for autonomous
vehicles, robotics and generative AI. So
to pull the curtain back on that and via
worldwide gig network is the ultimate
foundation for an AI data business.
Please welcome the global head of the
global head of Uber AI Dan Carpenter.
>> Thank you. Yeah, I appreciate the time.
So funny story, Uber was actually
founded here in Paris in 2008. One of
the reasons that initially was
instantiated is Travis Kalanick could
not find a taxi in the middle of the
night when it was raining outside. And
so there's a relative coincidence
speaking today relative to the company
founding.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the first topic is why is Ubero
the right foundation layer for a massive
AI data business and how does sort of 70
billion plus trips help you guys
effectively be the next AI data and
robotics all-in-one provider. Yeah, I
mean if you think back in the last 10
years where Uber's been spending a lot
of time in the AI space, it ranges
everything from rider management to
routing and telemetry and matching
people with the right location and the
right car and and also scaling
applications to global levels across
many different markets. And so we saw an
opportunity very similar to what you
know AWS found inside of Amazon to
externalize a lot of these platforms and
make them available to outside
customers. So we spent the last three
years building out this team known as
Uber AI solutions to make these
available ranging from data annotation
and labeling to mapping to autonomous
vehicles to model evals and agentic RL
gyms and a lot of these things you know
we're working with many of the
hyperscalers and the foundation labs uh
on physical data collection activities
as well which is really relevant for the
audience here today and so you know we
scale that through Uber's entire
platform of 9 million earners globally
which really gives what we think a
relatively unprecedented scale and
ability to get to not only kind of scale
data collection but also edge situations
that are important for a lot of robotics
training in the market today.
Awesome. Is there something that
particularly surprised you about the
overlap from Uber to Uber AI? Yeah, I
think that um you know we can talk more
about this but and folks have likely
seen the announcements around Uber AV
Labs which is one of our sister
organizations internally that's spending
a lot of time with our autonomous
partners and not only enabling the
broader ecosystem but also collecting
very significant amounts of of global
data across many different sensor types
and and modalities and we found a
natural transition of that physical data
collection effort to what we actually
need to provide in robotics especially
for real world navigation world models
HD mapping among other things that three
years ago, you know, we wouldn't have
said this was a big bet for the
business, but has really been an area
that we've been pulled through uh
overall and are really kind of scaling
in this area more broadly.
>> I mean, from your perspective, from
robotics standpoint, what have you guys
found to be some of the big challenges
you're facing? Yeah, I mean one of the
biggest challenges is collecting data,
finding sort of the right hires, racing
racing for hires with open AI, deep
mind, some of the big players
um kind of not only on the mission but
also on capital as well as kind of just
building our core system. So all of
those are important for us. Um I wanted
to ask about um how you guys kind of see
data collection at Uber. So obviously
LLMs had the internet to train on but
for robots that's not going to work. We
have seen several times today that we
collect data in several different ways.
Everybody has their own thesis of
collecting data.
>> Yeah.
>> What do you guys do to address the data
scarcity problem?
>> Yeah. I mean at risk of repeating some
of the other presenters that have
already been on stage today. I mean I
think physical intelligence put it well
in the fact that there is not an
internet for you know physical robotics
and collection right. you have over 300
million tokens of text and and video
that's available for training LLM
systems. And I think that this is an
area that is really a you know frontier
that a lot of folks are trying to figure
out. I mean if we were to collect enough
data for what would be a true you know
robotics model it would be 80 million
robots running 24/7 for 3 years right
and that's not something that is
scalable or or cost uh sensitive right
and so we view not only scaled
collection is important but also the
quality of those collection activities
where we can actually go get data the
different modalities and types whether
it's people's homes or or outside in the
physical world moving around and in your
case really specialized use cases like
oil and gas and government applications
and whatnot that you know we think
there's a tremendous frontier ahead of
us that really no one has scratched the
surface of yet from an overall uh you
data quality and excellence perspective.
>> Yeah, makes sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Min, we do a lot of tele operation
as well to collect data.
>> Yeah.
>> And finetune it and then clean it, prune
it and get it ready to actually being
used. It's quite quite a hassle.
>> Yeah. Um
is there any sort of specific in
infrastructure that you guys have built
out to generate or prune data for
yourself internally?
>> Yeah, so unfortunately we've been asked
today if Uber is making any of its
compute available to some of the parties
out there and unfortunately that's not
something we're selling just yet, but I
know that there would be a lot of
appetite for that. But I think you know
we have the ability to not only use
Uber's internal ecosystem from a um you
know compute perspective for a lot of
the annotation lab and labeling work
that we're doing but we also have the
benefit of Uber's uh entire application
ecosystem for onboarding a lot of the
folks that we have involved in these
tasks. So if it's a relatively, you
know, lowkilled, high volume task, we
can use many of the same rails that Uber
uses for drivers. That includes payment,
IP verification, uh, identity
verification, among many other things
that allow us to not only have security
around what it is that we're collecting,
but also knowing who's on the other end,
which is extremely important. And then
ensuring they get paid on time, on task,
and that we can bring repeatable uh
efforts forward to them. And like one of
the things that is really interesting is
especially for people who maybe don't
have the ability to drive or who don't
have a car, this presents new economic
earning opportunities for them too. And
that's really resonated a lot especially
with governments that are finding you
know new earning opportunities for their
citizens. And so we're really excited as
we're you know currently available in 30
countries worldwide uh to continue to
expand that and find you know
integration opportunities with local
municipalities to you know expand this
even further.
>> Yeah absolutely. I think in the future
we will see a galore of these platforms
that just connect remote workforces
across the planet kind of forcing the
pricing function of money
>> into the economy and serving as a
platform for for remote teley operation
effectively.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Do you see that being useful in a way to
also collect and label data as well?
>> Yeah. So I think edge cases are the name
of the game, right? someone uh in
autonomous vehicles, you have situations
whether it's snow, hard breaking, right
turns, difficult cities to navigate in
certain areas of Southeast Asia. There
aren't even street names, right, to work
on. And so that's where, you know, we've
learned a lot from our autonomous
labeling work, whe whether we had Uber
ATG back in 2018 and have since
progressed that into the partner
ecosystem. There's a lot of ways that we
have to kind of find specialized
opportunities to provide to our
customers. And so in the case of
robotics, we're seeing much of the same
thing where not only edge case
collection is important, but also the
searchability of that, right? How do we
surface things that may be useful for
their model that they may not be able to
get through other sources? And so that's
an important avenue we're continuing to
to poke on. But I think, you know, edge
cases more broadly is one. The second uh
two is the modality at which people
collect, right? whether it's phone based
harness based VR headsets uh some
particular application we try to be as
flexible as possible but I think there's
a lot of opportunity for more um
continuity and similarity among the way
that people are collecting data and how
we can make more open ecosystem there
too which is something that I'm
personally really excited about
>> makes sense how would you rate
simulation to real world data what's
your current mixture of bags that you
use for most clients is there sort of a
rule of thumb that you
or depends on sort of
>> not necessarily I mean I think in a lot
of cases because we're involving a lot
of parties that haven't previously done
data collection before I mean we want to
get to a place where you can call an API
have data collectors go out and do the
work for you but we're not quite there
yet from a customization perspective. So
unfortunately a lot of cases it's a it's
a case by case interaction with
customers and very servicesoriented but
I think that that gives us an
opportunity to again really kind of meet
customer demand and then learn along the
way so we can develop a better platform
and product right and that's kind of
within our DNA uh from a the original
BTOC business and what we can build from
a B2B perspective as well.
>> Amazing. And do you see sort of in the
future an avenue to pull data from real
Uber rights or potentially Uber Eats of
how a pizza is being delivered?
>> Yeah.
>> In sort of solving that problem
autonomously.
>> So today many of the partners within the
Uber ecosystem that we're working with
at uh in the autonomous vehicle sector,
you know, do have external sensors that
we're not collecting any of the internal
car data, but what they are seeing
outside of it. And so that allows us to
not only scale to multiple
municipalities, but also get many
hundreds of thousands of hours of
aggregate data overall and many
different situations on the same street,
sunrise, sunset, traffic, no traffic,
etc. And again, that's that's something
that we view having strong applications.
Now, can we move to a place where we
also have sensors on backpacks, on Uber
earners, on potential humanoids running
delivery opportunities for us? Yes,
those are things we want to explore and
and are actively finding opportunities
within that space. Makes perfect sense,
right?
>> And do you have any advice for the
general audience on how to sort of solve
the edge case problem as sort of
procedurally or at a high level?
>> I mean, I think diversity of data is
important. I know that there's many
companies here locally that are
providing a ton of different data
collection activities. You know, we've
heard that in certain markets there's a
lot of saturation, right? And so, I
think especially in Southeast Asia,
there's lots of people reusing and
repackaging the same data or using the
same people kind of overall. And so I
think expanding that to many different
loces is extremely important as we look
to various different model types and
different home types, different kitchen
layouts or different places that the
robotics robots may go. I think all of
that's really key and so you know we're
happy to work with other partners in the
community that may have access to things
that we do not and find ways that we can
co-sell together as well would be you
know tremendous opportunities. I mean we
want to build a a broad market within
this space and really as we've done in
autonomous systems be an aggregation
layer for a lot of you know robotics
opportunities down the road.
>> Makes sense. Do you guys deploy globally
or is it more of an American or European
focus? I
>> I would say today a lot of our requests
I mean Uber AI solutions itself operates
in 30 countries right now. Um I would
say much of our robotics data collection
work has primarily been centered in the
United States and Southeast Asia. Um,
we're getting a lot more requests for,
you know, other Asian markets like Japan
and Korea in addition to, you know,
areas that are super difficult like
subsaharan Africa, right? I mean, those
are things that are tough edge cases,
but that we, you know, are trying to
find ways to to scale into. And I think
that there's a lot of markets that are
maybe not in the top 20 from a from a
physical collection perspective that we
view an ability to move into fast and
and find ways to leverage our local
population there that we think would
benefit everybody.
>> Makes sense. Yeah.
>> Is there anything you do to sort of you
mentioned scaling so you do things
sustainable as you scale through you
know these millions of hours of training
data?
>> Yeah I mean I think a lot of these ear
the the people we call them earners who
we interact with I think this is a first
time opportunity for a lot of them.
They're learning how to collect data.
They're learning what good looks like.
And the more repeatability we can give
to these folks um the better. So we may
identify a population in a particular
market of a couple thousand people that
have done this before.
>> The more this flywheel spins for us, the
more customer requests we get. The more
we can keep them on the platform and
give them more opportunities to scale.
And that that I view is important. Just
giving someone a one-off $5 task is not
super exciting, right, or engaging. And
so we want to again increase that
velocity. And that comes with us scaling
the business, bringing on more customers
and and finding ways to again find find
uh different methodologies for the
collection effort. Right. Makes sense.
And where do you see the main
bottlenecks in scaling up that business
operation? Is it more in sort of the
physical kind of toughness of the
problem? It being hard to just make good
hardware or is it more about or capture
data or is it more about sort of the
lack of compute or more about like lack
of data?
>> I think I mean compute is constrained
for everybody whether it's a standard AI
case or robotics use case. I don't need
to repeat that. But I think that one of
the things that we've seen challenges
especially is headmounted collection,
right? It's uncomfortable for people to
wear a headband, it's awkward, it looks
weird, right? And so I think the more we
can move toward something that is
comfortable for an order to wear person
to wear long term. Uh grippers that are
easy to distribute and get back, right?
A lot of those things from a device
commonality perspective I think will be
better for the human experience part of
it. So we're exploring a lot of
different kind of logistics uh
approaches there. And then I think the
second thing is which we didn't expect
from the get-go is in certain locations
internet speed is a challenge right
someone's filming you know a 1080p video
over long form 10 plus minutes and they
either have challenges uploading it or
or uh the video does not upload in
totality and have to go back and do it
again or we've even had people that are
going to coffee shops to upload their
videos. So that's something that isn't
within our control, but we want to try
to validate ahead of time that they have
the right infrastructure in their home
or in the location they're going to to
actually conduct the collection
activity. And and I think the last thing
is quality, too. I mean, volume is one
thing, but getting people actually to do
something well, the video looks good.
It's not choppy. It doesn't cut out.
That requires, you know, both agentic
work, working through a model to assess
the quality, and then a second layer of
human in the loop that we all have to
get more efficient about over time.
Yeah,
>> makes sense.
>> And have you seen something that sounded
like science fiction sort of 18 months
ago?
>> Yeah.
>> Like something that would have sounded
like it was science fiction 18 months
ago and is now a reality at Uber AI.
>> I think a lot of people are talking
about household robotics. I mean, I
think that's a given of having a helper
around the house long term. I think that
there's been a couple of customers we
met with here and folks speaking earlier
working in the industrial space. I'm
particularly bullish on the A sector. I
think there's not been innovation in A
for 20 plus years. There's tremendous
monetization opportunities across every
geography for cropbased science,
fertilizers, you know, carbon robotics
from from my home state in Washington is
really exciting. And actually, my my
brother's a wine maker and he's testing
out carbon robotics right now at his
winery from a weed control perspective.
And so, I think the more those aren't
necessarily a humanoid modality, but
there's so many different applications
and and sizes and shapes and things that
I I'm really looking forward to seeing
kind of how it progresses in the next 5
years.
>> That's awesome. And my last question is,
do you actually see a certain form
factor having more of a potential than
other form factors across all these
applications?
>> Well, personally, I think, you know, I
know you're doing a lot of work in the
humanoid space with legs, right? And I
think the the thing that's interesting
is is how robots with legs navigate hard
to reach areas, areas that are moving or
changing under them and whatnot. And so,
I think I see kind of a dichotomy
between wheeled robots versus legs. But
overall, I think we're seeing from a lot
of the trends here that legs seem to be
witting out. But, uh, you know, it'll
take some time to fully get a a fully
st, you know, uh, stable, I guess,
platform overall in a lot of the edge
cases you guys are working in.
>> Makes sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you. Appreciate the time.
>> Likewise. Thanks.
>> All right. Thanks everyone.
>> Thank you all.